[Music]
amarillo texas is where we go now and
chancellor joins us on the line there
chancellor how can we help
hey yes sir thanks guys for taking my
phone call you bet
hey hey uh
so
kind of crazy here uh
i uh
i'm in a point at a point now to where
we are
my wife and i were completely out of
debt
and uh we've been doing the we did the
baby steps and we got gazelle intense
and
it seems
as if the gazelle intensity has
kind of taken over our lives um
we don't really know where to go from
here and it's not a bad situation by any
means you know we have
a nice savings account 15 going to our
retirement and uh
we got our kids
college funds on the way we're building
them
however we still have an influx of money
and we don't know what to do
now
so you've got leftover cash after
four and five and you're wondering what
do we do with it
yes sir how much money are we talking
uh right now we have about fifty six
thousand dollars in cash
that's on top of your emergency fund
yes well that's no no i'm sorry forty
one thousand we have fifty six thousand
total
okay forty one thousand is your
emergency fund
fifteen thousand oh okay okay so we got
15 in the emergency fund what's outside
of the emergency fund in cash
forty one thousand dollars okay there we
go all right now we're cooking with gas
so you've got baby step six paying off
the house early and you're saying hey
we've been going real hard is it okay
for us to slow down and enjoy our lives
uh
uh yeah i guess so um i guess
my fear
is you know with college prices being
college tuition being so expensive
i just don't know how much
what's the cap where to stop where to
start i mean
really just
right yeah i mean my kids are my biggest
how old are these kids
well i have a nine-year-old stepson and
i have a one-year-old daughter
okay we've got 17 years till college and
we've got another nine years till
college you've got plenty of time you
guys have done really well
i'm not super worried about them being
able to afford going to college
debt-free
with the way you guys have handled your
finances is that what you're worried
about will be will we be able to afford
it
um yeah
i am worried about that i am
um
but more or less you know i would like
uh
i like my kids you know i'm i'm 27 years
old i i
my wife's 29 but i fear every day that i
just don't want my kids
needing anything
ever
yeah if that makes sense well i mean
you're a great dad for wanting that but
i don't want you living in this fear
ever you said i'm living in fear every
day
uh that borders on paranoia at that
point and so i want you guys to you guys
have done so well you've worked so hard
you have forty one thousand dollars
sitting there in liquid cash so have
some fun have you guys been on a
vacation
well we do we do enjoy our vacation but
we do a chancellor
chancellor can i speak to you as a dad
uh of three i totally understand your
heart that you don't want your kids to
want for anything but the way that
sounds
is if
you have the pressure that you've put on
yourself
to fund their entire life
the way you said it sounded way more
than college
and george has already made it clear
you're going to be fine on college fund
and you just keep doing what we teach
there and they're going to be fine
they're going to have plenty
but this idea that i don't want my kids
to want for anything i completely
understand that believe me i understand
you
but your job is not to fund their life
they're gonna they have a role that they
were created to fill there's work they
want to do there's dreams that they have
it's that's on them to do that it's not
on you to fund their entire life
okay
okay
you needed to hear that didn't you
yes sir yeah man yes sir you're a good
dude
you're a good dude
look the baby steps are the baby steps
you're doing it man keep walking it out
relax
outside of that
your kids are going to make their own
decisions
you
your job is not to now look if you want
to do a mutual fund and something for
them down the road and give them a great
start whatever and put some nice strings
on all that that's all good but again i
feel this heavy weight on you it needs
to be released today
okay so
i guess that leads me into my next
question um
what could i start doing you know like
i have a really good job i can't
complain about my job however i don't
absolutely love my job
but
you know i
i have this dream of
you know working for myself or tell me
what that would be
i don't care how pretty it sounds and
how great of a business plan you have
tell me what right now in this very
moment
you would do for yourself
if you knew you couldn't fail what kind
of business what would you do and
honestly i think i would do landscaping
i truly love landscaping i've done it i
did it
okay now listen
chancellor you're in a position man
where you can start to plan this out and
start this thing on the side with no
risk
how much money do you make in your
current job
well it's a little bit
it fluctuates quite a bit but i'd say
between 130 and 150. all right so let's
just pick 150 as a number you would want
to replace and if i promised you that
you could make 150
today
running your landscaping business how
quickly would you resign
right
now it my man so here's the deal what is
it going to take for you
to eventually start that business
and take care of your family in that
business there's a couple ways you could
do this you could keep busting it the
way you're busting it you got some money
right here george he's got some money
that can begin to be the seed for
starting that landscaping business and
maybe you do it on the side you hire a
couple young guys and you're the face of
it and
you build this thing up you build it up
and you get enough money in that
landscaping business account that you've
got six months of your salary there and
you know if i just go at this full time
i've got the pipeline full i can go this
becomes a math
equation
that's right i start today
start pursuing today by planning and
thinking through how would i do it
what's the best way to do it save it all
up and step into it or start it on the
side and establish it i really like
starting it on the side and establishing
it by the way and chancellor you can do
that now can you not
yes sir i actually you know i have about
10 yards a week i do right now oh look
at that i had a sneaky suspicion george
that he was already dead my yard's next
man that's i'm so glad people have a
passion for landscaping ken because i
have zero yeah so listen man you have
done so well you're 27 years old you
make 150 000
you're in baby step 6 you have a pile of
cash
you need to let go of this fear and
start getting excited about your life
again your kids are going to be fine you
need to start dreaming and uh really
going after this thing like ken's
talking about yeah and you've got it
chancellor those 10 yards
every nickel
that you make
uh or rather keep after you pay for the
you know the lawn care equipment and all
the things in gas right
um
that's just going in that side account
and i'm building that side account up
and i'm building it and i'm building it
and i'm building it and i'm trying to
figure out can i put six months of my
salary what i currently make in that
account and i'm building up the clients
and i'm going i know that i can blow
this thing wide open
and there's no risk here george you know
we talk about stepping from the boat
right on the dock that's what this side
hustle is
and then he's going to be in such great
financial shape
that he doesn't have the pressure that a
lot of entrepreneurs face it's amazing
how many times people get their
financial life in order and then they
can focus on purpose and career